oh we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
uh we got a voicemail late last week
about this new march 4th
thing there are q anon people
who i don't even know that i can say
they believe it they are saying maybe
they believe it
q anon people are now saying that
through some kind of
bizarre technicality donald trump is
going to
resume his presidency on march 4th
and i said isn't this in some sense
mental illness
delusional in a way and a caller left me
a voicemail saying it is but there's
also some of that on the left let's take
a listen
the latest march 4th q and on thing
let's call it what it is
it's mental illness okay but the
democrats are also
guilty of having mental illness they
think this is the wizard of oz
where at some point the republicans are
going to discover that
they had a brain the whole time they had
courage the whole time
they had conscience the whole time they
just didn't know it
right it was there all along well guess
what alice
that's never going to happen because
they don't have courage they don't have
conscience
and they don't have a brain and this
march 4th
babel is mental illness and i would
propose
that to give it any media attention at
all
even on admittedly an anti-q and on
youtube progressive channel still
gives it a voice that it doesn't deserve
all right so there is a big admonishment
there but no i think that
the the what i what i completely agree
with is
you know throughout the trump president
for law for decades honestly it happened
during george w
bush it kept happening but certainly
during the trump presidency
there would be the sense where oh
this is too much even the trumpian
lunatics aren't going to defend this
clearly republican senators are now
going to say this
is too far and of course it never
happened and
it is in a sense insanity to keep
repeating the same expectation
absent any evidence that should make us
think this is too far
this is too low even for republicans to
think no it never is
it never is and i do think that that's
an important
uh important takeaway and uh the caller
is absolutely right
on the bonus show today house
impeachment managers
are defending their decision not to call
witnesses
in the trump impeachment trial after
they voted to call witnesses
that's one story number two joe biden is
launching a review
of the guantanamo bay detention center
and he is
planning to close it before leaving
office we're still doing this
yes we're still talking about closing
gitmo maybe joe biden can get it done
and parlor is back again it's like the
website that just won't die parlor is
back again
we'll talk a little bit about the latest
iteration and what uh
impact it's having on the conservative
dialogue i guess we would call it
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
joinpackman.com i'll see you then